การคำนวณอย่างรับผิดชอบหมายถึง
การพัฒนา quantum computing
โดยตระหนักถึงพลังของมัน
และผลกระทบที่อาจเกิดขึ้น เมื่อพูดถึงความรับผิดชอบ
เราต้องพัฒนาและใช้เทคโนโลยี
บนพื้นฐานของหลักการที่กำหนดไว้ล่วงหน้า เพื่อช่วยป้องกัน
และลดความเสียหายที่อาจเกิดขึ้น
ขณะเดียวกันก็ส่งเสริมโซลูชันที่มีความ
ครอบคลุมเชิงรุกและมีความรับผิดชอบ ที่ IBM
เราขับเคลื่อนด้วยความรู้สึกรับผิดชอบ
ต่อสังคมมาหลายสิบปี วันนี้เราเรียกตัวเองว่าตัวเร่งปฏิกิริยา
ที่ทำให้โลกทำงานได้ดีขึ้น นั่นหมายความว่าเรา
มีหน้าที่พิจารณาผลกระทบของ
เทคโนโลยีที่เราสร้างและนำไปใช้
ขณะที่เราพัฒนาเทคโนโลยีใหม่นี้
การตัดสินใจที่เราทำวันนี้จะส่งผลต่ออนาคต
และการตัดสินใจเหล่านี้
มีศักยภาพที่จะส่งผลกระทบอย่างมหาศาลต่อสังคม
ตัวอย่างเช่น คุณอาจต้องตัดสินใจว่าจะพัฒนาแอปพลิเคชันที่
ช่วยเหลือเพียงไม่กี่ผู้มีส่วนได้ส่วนเสีย หรือ
แอปฯ ที่อาจแก้ปัญหาสังคมได้
เราหวังว่าคุณในฐานะลูกค้าจะสามารถคิด
เกี่ยวกับการพัฒนา quantum computing อย่างรับผิดชอบ
การคิดอย่างรับผิดชอบช่วยให้ธุรกิจของคุณสร้างความไว้วางใจ
กับนักลงทุนและผู้บริโภค
พร้อมกับสร้างชื่อเสียงด้านความซื่อสัตย์
และการยอมรับจากพนักงาน
และลูกค้า ในทางกลับกัน
ยังช่วยปกป้องคุณจากข่าวร้าย ค่าปรับ
และบทลงโทษต่างๆ ในวิดีโอนี้
เราจะแนะนำข้อพิจารณาด้านความรับผิดชอบที่สำคัญ
เพื่อหารือกับทีม
ขณะที่คุณสำรวจ quantum computing
และแอปพลิเคชันต่างๆ เมื่อพูดถึง quantum computing
การคิดและลงมือทำอย่างรับผิดชอบ
หมายถึงการทำตามชุดหลักการ
และค่านิยมเพื่อชี้นำการพัฒนา
และการนำเทคโนโลยีไปใช้งาน
ตัวอย่างเช่น นี่หมายถึงการโปร่งใส
ทั้งข้อจำกัดและความสามารถ
ของ quantum computing ในปัจจุบัน เรามีภาษา
ในสัญญาของเราที่กำหนดให้ลูกค้า IBM Quantum
ใช้ระบบของเราอย่างรับผิดชอบ
และห้ามนำระบบของเรา
ไปใช้เพื่อวัตถุประสงค์ที่ผิดกฎหมายหรือชั่วร้าย
เราเรียกสิ่งนี้ว่าการใช้งานอย่างรับผิดชอบ
และข้อกำหนดการใช้งานที่ยอมรับได้
ภาษาเหล่านี้กำลังส่งผลต่อแนวคิดของลูกค้าเราแล้ว
ในการพัฒนา quantum
สำหรับกรณีใช้งานของพวกเขา เรายัง
สามารถช่วยกำหนดทิศทางของ quantum computing
ได้โดยการเลือกว่าจะพัฒนาแอปพลิเคชันใด
เพื่อพัฒนาและเร่งความเร็ว
เพื่อป้องกันการใช้งานที่ไม่รับผิดชอบ
จากเทคโนโลยีของเรา เรายังพัฒนา IBM Quantum ที่แข็งแกร่ง
เทคโนโลยีที่ปลอดภัย ขณะที่คุณกำลังคิด
ว่าจะใช้ quantum computing อย่างไรและเพื่ออะไร
ให้แน่ใจว่าพูดอย่างสมจริงเกี่ยวกับความคาดหวัง
ต่อ quantum computing และระยะเวลา
ที่คุณหวังจะนำ quantum มาใช้
อย่านำเสนอ quantum computing
ว่าเป็นเรื่องลึกลับ แต่พยายามอธิบายอย่างสมจริง
ในฐานะฮาร์ดแวร์การคำนวณ
ที่เป็นไปตามกฎของฟิสิกส์ควอนตัม
ให้แน่ใจว่ากรณีใช้งาน quantum computing ของคุณ
มีความครอบคลุมเชิงรุก
และพิจารณาผู้มีส่วนได้ส่วนเสียทุกฝ่าย
เพื่อประเมินขอบเขต
ของผลกระทบทางสังคมเชิงลบที่อาจเกิดขึ้น
ให้แน่ใจว่าคุณกำหนดหลักการที่ชัดเจน
และค่านิยมสำหรับการสำรวจกรณีใช้งาน
และการพัฒนา ขอบคุณ
ที่รับชม เราหวังว่า
เมื่อคุณนำ quantum computing ที่มีประโยชน์สู่โลก
คุณจะคิดด้วยว่าทำสิ่งนี้อย่างรับผิดชอบได้อย่างไร
เดอะ เดอะ